what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so I want to try something new here I
want to take a look at characters as
they exist in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and compare them to the couple
of counterparts but only in terms of
powers it's no secret that like
characters in the MCU are deep powered
but my question is is it possible for
them to reach the common book levels of
power and and in this one I want to talk
about Scarlet Witch now here's the thing
Scarlet Witch in the comics in the early
days of the comics the early Avengers
stories she's very similar to her Marvel
Cinematic Universe counterpart which is
to say she can do like a little bit of
hex manipulation and like that's it
the idea of Scarlet Witch originally was
that she could is kind of like been luck
in her favor just kind of like slight
reality manipulation but there was
really nothing more to it than that but
all this changed over that while it's
changed over the years um West Coast
Avengers the House of M post house of M
Avengers disassembled which led into
house of him well you have a Marvel
Comics is you have a character called
kaatham Agathon is one of like who is
what we call the Elder Gods on in Marvel
Comics in the early days of Earth you
didn't really have humanity you
basically just had like these gods
roaming around and eventually this led
to like a massive civil war between them
but this was all kind of like kicked off
bike-a-thon who was like the main bad
guy so to speak eventually when like the
Demiurge consumed most of the gods cthe
own and likes in iraq and like a bunch
of other a bunch of other beings just
kind of like took off to alternate
realities alternate dimensions and just
kind of resided there but cathode had
always sought to find a way back to
earth and basically like conquer the
world for himself where there are
different schemes and stuff that
happened over the years all this kind of
coincided with the birth of wanda you
know when she and Pho were born by Magda
when they were born in on wundagore
mountain with a high evolutionary all i
kinda stuff cthe ona basically like
reached out and kind of quote-unquote
touched her and what that basically
meant was that somewhere along the line
C'thun would like use her as a vessel to
bring himself back and over the years
that's happened a time or two like
secret empire it happened things like
that were like his own takes total
control of Wanda and possesses her in
her entirety in what if stories has
happened were like Wanda kills everyone
but for the most part her powers weren't
really all that specials you could just
kind of do some things here and there
now this all goes into Avengers
disassembled which really feeds and like
the idea that she had kids so to wind
the clock back when DC launched West
Coast Avengers the idea was to have like
a Scarlet Witch and vision centric team
and it kind of focused on their
relationship as well as like another
Avengers team that kind of existed on
the west coast is way back in my 1982
and the idea here was that you had
vision of Scarlet Witch who of course
were a couple they were married and they
had kids
their kids were william and thomas
maxima and what we ended up finding out
in West Coast Avengers number 52 was
that they never actually existed instead
they were basically kids who were
created by the Scarlet Witch when she
took like the essence of Mephisto like
at like a portion of Mephisto and like
created her children he gave them souls
Mephisto of course is kind of like the
stand-in for Satan in in the Marvel
Universe but ultimately this was all
kind of reconciled and the kids were
removed now the reason for this was
because of the fact that like Scarlet
Witch envisioned getting married was
weird enough the two of them having kids
was just like a little too weird even
for comics anything with West Coast
Avengers like dying down you know I'm
really losing popularity and eventually
going away a lot of those themes were
wrapped up the issue was that if mall
was gonna launch house of am and they
were gonna start with Avengers
disassembled they needed a means to kind
of like kick it all off to kind of make
it Punk and so what happened was a
Scarlet Witch
she was an Avengers mansion in the wash
but given her a hard time about having
kids or something long those lines and
then she had memories of having her sons
and and for her the question was where
are they and so eventually what ends up
happening is a Scarlet Witch goes crazy
believing the Avengers have kidnapped
her kids and then like goes on a warpath
basically so like she manipulates
reality she makes Tony Stark appear
drunk that totally like tanks the value
of Stark Industries Tony Stark cannot
bankroll the Avengers anymore so they
disband and then she launches an attack
on Avengers mansion which leads to like
the death of Hawkeye and all these
different things and when when the
smokes all said and done Doctor Strange
like crates the spell where she ends up
seeing like all kinds of these horrible
memories and everything and she is a
passing out and so magneto takes her to
Genosha which used to be a safe refuge
for mutants until Cassandra Nova
destroyed it killed like 16 millions and
then Scarlet Witch just hangs out there
with magneto and Charles Xavier under
the hope that her mind can basically be
fixed in like her fractured state now
this goes into the events of like house
of M and that's when you end up finding
out that there was no way to like fix
her quote-unquote and so Charles Xavier
calls together like the x-men the
Avengers and basically says like we have
to kill Scarlet Witch and so of course
Quicksilver steps in and Quicksilver
says no no you know he runs the Scarlet
Witch and says hey look like you can fix
everything you can make reality perfect
and so using Scarlet Witch
she basically I guess what Scarlet Witch
kind of being manipulated being in like
a fractured mental state she ends up
like kidnapping Charles Xavier uses her
powers scans his mind and then learns
like the subconscious desires of
everybody on earth and then recreates
reality into the House of M universe so
like Carol Danvers who always wanted to
be seen as like a great superhero like
the most popular hero in the world
becomes that Peter Parker basically like
has
his life the dream life he always wanted
seve Rodgers like never became Captain
America I mean he was but like he ended
up just going on and like growing old
and like that was that he was never
frozen in ice for however many years he
was frozen they're just little things
like that you know small little tidbits
here and there but nonetheless you know
like like Wolverine wakes up and of
course I've got a video on house of a me
you guys are welcome to check out but
wolf rein wakes up all his memories are
restored he realizes reality isn't
supposed to be that way he contacts a
girl named Lela Miller who also knows
the same thing she's told other
superheroes about it and by going
through and Conan quote waking them up
various heroes like like Emma Frost and
Cyclops and so on and so forth become
aware of how how things are supposed to
be and they all believe that that
Scarlet Witch was the one that was
behind all this well you end up learning
of course the Quicksilver was the one
who did this who got her to do it and
the magneto freaks out kills Quicksilver
and then Scarlet Witch loses her mind
resurrects Quicksilver from the dead and
then sets everything back to rights but
says no more mutants in the process and
that of course leads to 98% of the
mutant population losing their powers
now at the outset that was it that
seemed like that's all there was 98% of
the population loses their powers in the
main Marvel Universe and that's all
there is to it the skull at which was
vastly more powerful than that and in
fact it actually feeds into old man
Logan so what is up happening is in the
aftermath of house of M you end up
having the unive having beasts I think
it is who's investigating what's going
on and hypothesizes that the actions of
the Scarlet Witch did not affect only
their reality it affected the whole
multiverse and so like 98% of the mutant
population across the multiverse lost
their powers and this this feeds in the
old man Logan because if you go and you
read the old man Logan stories we know
from that universe that Wolverine was
basically tricked into killing all the
x-men and then after that like no more
mutants are born anymore there's a point
where Emma Frost kind of makes us
offhand remark she's like you know
mutants were just a blip on the radar we
thought that we were like the next stage
of human evolution but that's not the
case and then you look at the actions of
Scarlet Witch and it seems like she's
the one that affected it especially when
you bring in the hypothesis of beasts
but she affected the whole multiverse so
you know it's entirely possible -
Scarlet Witch stripped 98% of the mutant
population of their powers across the
entire multiverse and if that's true
that's an insane level of power now when
it comes to the nature of the Scarlet
Witch there's a big difference here
Scarlet Witch of the mobile cinematic
universe just kind of uses some magic
and some things happen and she makes
some weird hand gestures and looks funny
but but there's not a whole lot that she
does there she also has a power to lose
her accent but there's there's not a
whole lot that she does there for the
most part she's not
that powerful she's really more like
Jean Grey and from from Marvel Comics
back in the early days where her powers
are basically like telekinesis and
that's really you know and you see the
physical manifestation of telekinesis
and that's about it there's not much
doing there but the question becomes
does the aspect of C'thun tap into the
Scarlet Witch because if she harnesses
that power like she did you know during
the house of a man all I kind of stuff
doesn't mean she's gonna be on like a
whole nother level
but she's gonna be insanely powerful far
more powerful than someone like Doctor
Strange but by and large the powers just
don't really compare there I mean you're
talking about a character in the in the
comics who was like multiversal level
powerful who for a brief moment in time
was able to pull that off now this kind
of goes into the nature of scarlet
witch's powers in in Marvel Comics in
Marvel Comics there are two types of
people who can affect reality and a lot
of individuals get these confused and
it's very easy to do because if you're
not familiar with comics you can't
really under you can't really notice the
subtle nuances but there's what's called
reality warper or reality manipulators
and then matter manipulators and there
are two distinctly different things but
it's easy to confuse them so take
someone like like Mad Jim Jasper's right
he's like really really powerful but he
has to have a reality to manipulate
right like if the universe is clay he
has to be able to have that clay to do
anything with it if there's no clay
there he can't do anything he's just a
guy who's exists and that's it we know
that from those stories when he was
teleported to a massive void of what
used to be a universe and it's just an
empty blank space and there's nothing he
can do he's just a guy who's there but
then you look at someone like like
Franklin Richards Franklin Richards can
just create reality right like he can
create something out of nothing you know
he can go into a huge empty space that
is devoid of a universe and then create
one the kids got all kinds of crazy
powers Scarlet Witch she's a matter
manipulator she's not a reality warburg
The Scarlet Witch cannot create
something out of nothing
she can't create a universe she doesn't
have that kind of power the Scott at
which is capable of like altering the
the existing form of reality and is
still pretty powerful I mean changing
people's memories different things like
that but she's she's capable of like
like altering matter not to give you
perspective on what that means it's just
rearranging the atomic structure of
things and so she could turn a hat into
a teacup she can just rearrange the
atomic structure of that hat and turn it
into something else that's the kind of
power she possesses but it's not
something she possesses consistently it
was for in era in time for a few years
of Marvel Comics and then that's it her
power does kind of went back to his
previous states and she's been that way
ever since that
powers not something she has in in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but again
DMC use kind of stayed away from from
the notion of vast reality-warping
powers well probably see that somewhere
along the line and there's ways to pull
that off I mean we know that she and
vision or a couple we know that she and
vision are together you could easily
have her like come back after the events
of Avengers 4 and then like vision
doesn't return or vision returns and
like his his he's basically like he was
when he lost his essence in the comics
it he was just like a white Android and
he lost his personality and everything
lost them the Mitchell patters of Wonder
Man have you don't know what that means
it's not a great big huge deal but the
fact remains like there could be
something that could set in motion the
events that lead her to becoming how
powerful she was during like house of
ammon and you know post house of him but
as it stands right now the powers are
night and day she's much much much
weaker and in the movies that she is in
the comics and in fact again her
character in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is more similar to Jean Grey in
like 1960s 1970s Marvel Comics then she
is to like actual Scarlet Witch in
Marvel Comics so it's almost like a
total change up now what's the x-men are
unveiled that'll probably change and
like her powers will adjust but at the
moment again there's there's no real
comparison there but you know it for the
most part it's interesting to me you
know it's kind of intriguing but let me
you guys think about this idea down in
the comments section oh you guys think
about this whole thing
I don't know I'm just kind of throwing
an idea out there I have no idea people
will be receptive to it or not just
trying something new and yeah if you are
new here to comment explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the rock or if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]